PAUL SMITH: Well, I've got one
other very big difference that
you find, and it's something
that being in education as a
university lecturer I'm very
aware of, and, of course,
working with the French and
working in the English system,
and that's the way that
the French mark work.
Here at the University of
Nottingham, we use a system of
marking out of 100.
But in France, right across
the board, throughout the
education system, whether it's
at university or at school
level, you're not marked
out of 100, you're
marked out of 20.
And I think that this goes
back to-- and again, the
actual reasons aren't really
known, but I think it goes
back to the medieval period when
people used 20 as a base
number, as a base
for counting.
And they would count
things out of 20.
And nowadays in France, and
historically in France,
whenever you'd get your piece
of work back, you would have
your mark expressed out of 20.
So whether you're at university,
completing your
degree, whether you're doing
your baccalaureate--
that's the French equivalent
of an A level--
you're getting a mark out of--
well, if you're doing OK, you
get 10 out of 20.
That's all right, but
it's not fabulous.
If you get that, then you're
doing a bit better, obviously.
Everybody would be pretty much
satisfied with a mark
of 12 out of 20.
If you're a little bit ahead
of the race, if you're a
little bit better than
everybody else,
then 14 out of 20.
The real high flyers are
getting 16 out of 20.
The top people get
18 out of 20.
But nobody gets 20 out of 20,
because there is no such thing
as perfection.
-It's impossible to get 20.
PAUL SMITH: You can't
get 20 out of 20.
It never happens.
Because you could have 19 out
of 20, but there will always
be something that is not quite
right with your work.
And the reason for that is--
here in this system, we could
actually award a student 100
out of 100.
Not so much in the arts.
It doesn't tend to happen,
but it could happen.
It can certainly happen
in the sciences.
But there is always going
to be something that
is not quite right--
there is just a missing touch.
In a piece of work in France,
they will always see
you lose one mark.
And everybody accepts that.
The idea is that if you get 20
out of 20, then somebody's
made a mistake in the marking.
The absolute top you can
get is 19 out of 20.
And that's accepted
across the board.
-Is that even the case if,
say, it was I gave my
mathematics student 20
multiplication questions, and
clearly they got all 20 right.
Do you still dock
them for that?
PAUL SMITH: No, you don't dock
them in the mark in that
sense, but it will be scaled.
So you would have a
scaling system.
Let's say you set them 100
questions and they got 100
right, then there would be a
scaling system, which says
that a mark of 100 equals 19.
And all the other marks would
be scaled to the scale
between 1 and 19.
In fact, the scale
is not 1 to 20.
The scale is 1 to 19.
But everybody knows
what it means.
That's the other
thing as well.
So it's very clear that you know
what 10 out of 20 means.
8 out of 20, oh, dear.
When you're beginning to get
below 8, then you really
haven't put in the yards.
-So, Paul, if I said to you,
I've got a test for you.
What is the capital of France?
PAUL SMITH: Yup, Paris.
Yup.
-Well done.
19 out of 20.
PAUL SMITH: Well--
-Is that how it works?
PAUL SMITH: I'd say that's a
little bit easy, but yeah,
that would be right.
Yes, the French would say,
well done, 19 out of 20.
--a word for 70.
Instead, what they do is
they count to 60--
-And the traditional Chinese
character for
[CHINESE], which is used--
PAUL SMITH: --and add 10.
So whereas we go to 60 and then
go 70, a French person
goes to 60, but then
goes to 60 plus 10.